SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US. AS
YOU KNOW, WE CONTINUE TO WELCOME
ALL OF YOU HERE IN PERSON. WE
WILL ALLOW SIX MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY PER SIDE. BUT AS USUAL
HERE, DON'T YOU DON'T NEED TO
FEEL FREE TO USE IT ALL IF YOU
DON'T NEED TO. BUT WE ALLOW FOR
A FULL AND FAIR HEARING, SO TELL
US WHAT YOU WANT TO TELL US. ONE
BILL WAS PULLED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING, ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB
1316, ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN,
EMERGENCY SERVICES, PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
WHEN WE HAVE FOLKS HERE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE WILL HAVE
EIGHT BILLS ON THE AGENDA. TWO
OF THEM ARE BEING ARE PLACED ON
OUR PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 1965.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO,
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS, AND ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
AB 2119. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER A
MENTAL HEALTH. SO WITH THAT,
LET'S START WITH OUR FIRST ITEM
FOR HEARING TODAY. ITEM NUMBER
TWO, ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN. FOOD
DATE LABELING. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. I AM PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT AJR TEN, WHICH WOULD
URGE OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ENACT THE BIPARTISAN FOOD DATE
LABELING BILL OF 2023.
CURRENTLY, GROCERY STORES OFFER
PRODUCTS WITH ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT FOOD LABELS LIKE
EXPIRES ON BEST BEFORE, ENJOY,
BUY AND SELL, BUY TO NAME A FEW.
THESE LABELS CONSISTENTLY
MISLEAD AND CONFUSE CONSUMERS.
SELL BY DATES, FOR EXAMPLE, ARE
USED TO SHOW GROCERS WHEN TO
ROTATE STOCK, AND THEY ARE
GENERALLY MEANINGLESS TO THE
CONSUMER. THE RESULT OF THIS
CONSUMER CONFUSION IS STAGGERING
. THE AMOUNT OF FOOD THAT IS
WASTED IS, ACCORDING TO ONE
STUDY, IS AS MUCH AS 20% BECAUSE
OF CONFUSION ABOUT LABELS AT A
TIME WHEN PRICES AT THE GROCERY
STORE HAVE NEVER BEEN HIGHER,
REDUCING FOOD WASTE IS ONE OF
THE BEST WAYS TO ENSURE OUR
CONSTITUENTS SAVE MONEY ON
GROCERIES. AJR TEN WOULD DECLARE
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPORT FOR THE
BIPARTISAN FOOD DATE LABELING
ACT OF 2023, SHOWING THAT OUR
STATE SUPPORTS PUTTING AN END TO
THESE TO CONSUMER CONFUSION
SURROUNDING THESE FOOD DATE
LABELS, WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS ANDREA
COLLINS FROM THE NATURAL NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
ERIKA PARKER FROM CALIFORNIA'S
AGAINST WASTE. PLEASE COME ON
DOWN. YOU'RE WELCOME TO JOIN US
AT THE TABLE. PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD AND
THEN PROCEED. AND WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ANDREA COLLINS WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. AND
WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION TEN BECAUSE IT BUILDS
ON WORK ALREADY DONE BY THE
STATE TO ADDRESS A SYSTEMIC
CAUSE OF FOOD WASTE WITH
IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR HEALTH, OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR ECONOMY. AJR
TEN CALLS ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MIRROR WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES VERSION OF THE
BILL IS BIPARTISAN AND ALREADY
HAS SUPPORT FROM FIVE CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTATIVE CO-SPONSORS,
ALONG WITH A HOST OF SUPPORT
FROM THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY. AND
RIGHT NOW, THERE'S NO WAY OF
KNOWING WHICH DATES ON OUR FOOD
ARE ACTUALLY SAFETY DATES AND
WHICH INDICATE PEAK QUALITY.
INSTEAD, CONSUMERS ARE LEFT TO
GUESS AT WHAT IS INFO IS
INTENDED TO BE RELAYED BY THE
DATE ON THE PACKAGE, AND THESE
INCOMPREHENSIBLE DATE LABELS ARE
A LEADING CAUSE OF FOOD WASTE.
WE NEED CONSISTENT DATE LABELS
SO THAT PEOPLE STOP TOSSING GOOD
FOOD PREMATURELY, AND SO THAT WE
HAVE CLARITY ON WHICH FOODS ARE
REALLY A HEALTH CONCERN. AFTER A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME HAS
PASSED, CONFUSION OVER
EXPIRATION DATES IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR 20% OF THE WASTED FOOD IN
OUR HOMES, AND MORE THAN 80% OF
AMERICANS REPORT TOSSING FOOD
BECAUSE IT'S PAST DATE, AN
AVERAGE AMERICAN FAMILY LOSES
ABOUT $1,500 TO UNEATEN FOOD AND
ELIMINATING CONFUSION ABOUT
WHETHER THAT FOOD IS STILL GOOD
WILL KEEP SOME OF THAT MONEY IN
THE POCKETS OF CALIFORNIANS. AND
ENSURING THAT ALL OF US
UNDERSTAND WHEN FOOD IS STILL
GOOD WILL HELP US ALLEVIATE
PRESSURE TO TOSS FOOD THAT COULD
HAVE NOURISHED US. DEFINING A
STANDARD FOR CONSUMER TARGETED
DATE LABELS PROVIDES CLARITY ON
WHEN FOOD ACTUALLY POSES A
SAFETY RISK, AND IT REDUCES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF DISCARDING GOOD
FOOD. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS ON
THE DUAL CRISES OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND FOOD SECURITY, BOTH
OF WHICH ARE EXACERBATED BY FOOD
WASTE AND BOTH OF WHICH EXTEND
BEYOND OUR STATE BORDERS,
REQUIRING THAT THE ENTIRE NATION
FOLLOW OUR EXAMPLE. SO AJR TEN
IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD WAY FOR YOU
TO ENCOURAGE FURTHER ACTION ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS IN ALL
AMERICANS, AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. HI, ERICA PARKER
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE,
AMERICANS THROW AWAY NEARLY 66
MILLION TONS OF FOOD WASTE EACH
YEAR. AND CONSUMER CONFUSION
OVER DATE LABELS IS A LEADING
CAUSE. THE FOOD CYCLE DOESN'T
END AT THE TRASH CAN, AND FOOD
WASTE COMES WITH A SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL PRICE.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 50
DIFFERENTLY PHRASED LABELS IN
THE US. EACH TERM CAN BE USED TO
COMMUNICATE DIFFERENT THINGS
WHEN USED BY DIFFERENT BRANDS,
AND SOME DON'T HAVE LIKE SOME
DATE LABELS CONTAIN NO
EXPLANATION NEXT TO THEM AT ALL.
ADDITION ORPHALI FOOD BANKS AND
OTHER FOOD DONATION PROGRAMS
EXPERIENCE DIFFICULTY
DISTRIBUTING FOOD WHEN IT HAS AN
EXPIRED DATE ON IT, EVEN IF THE
DATE ON THE PACKAGE IS INTENDED
TO COMMUNICATE FOOD QUALITY
RATHER THAN THE SAFETY OF THE
FOOD ITEM, THIS KEEPS EDIBLE
FOOD FROM HUNGRY CITIZENS. WHEN
1 IN 8 PEOPLE IN THE US
EXPERIENCE FOOD INSECURITY, A
MAJOR STUDY FOUND THAT
STANDARDIZING DATE LABELS IS THE
SINGLE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO REDUCE FOOD WASTE. AS ANDREA
MENTIONED, AJ10 COMES WITH THE
ADDED BENEFIT OF KEEPING MONEY
IN THE POCKETS OF CALIFORNIANS.
ENACTMENT OF THE FEDERAL FOOD
DATE LABELING ACT BUILDS ON THE
EXISTING EFFORTS TO REDUCE FOOD
WASTE GOING TO LANDFILLS AND
PROTECT NATURAL RESOURCES, AND
FOR THESE REASONS, WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MA'AM. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NONE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE. LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO MY COLLEAGUE ON
THE DAIS. COLLEAGUE? ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS OR CONCERNS?
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. OKAY.
IT'S YOUR DAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AS WELL?
WHEN THE TIME COMES, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE, AND AS SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE WILL TAKE
THE MOTION AND WE'LL TAKE THE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. NEXT ITEM, ITEM
NUMBER THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
1842. ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES,
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS. AB 1842
PROHIBITS COMMERCIAL HEALTH
INSURERS FROM IMPOSING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION RULES THAT CREATE
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT MEDICATIONS
SUCH AS BUPRENORPHINE OR
NALTREXONE CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVE TREATMENT FOR MANY
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS BY
TREATING, CRAVING AND WITHDRAWAL
SYMPTOMS. HOWEVER, MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT ASSISTED
TREATMENT IS UNDERUSED DUE TO
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENTS, WHICH CREATE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS THAT DELAY
OR INTERRUPT ACCESS TO EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT. AB 1842 IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP THAT WILL
REDUCE OVERDOSE RATES AND SAVE
LIVES. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS DOCTOR
AMY MULLIN, WHO WAS A PROFESSOR
OF EMERGENCY MEDICINE AND
DIVISION CHIEF OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE AT UC DAVIS. SHE IS
ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BRIDGE PROGRAM.
DOCTOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I'M REPRESENTING
ALSO 270 OF THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE WORK WITH FOR CALIFORNIA
BRIDGE PROGRAM. WE ARE DEDICATED
TO PROVIDING RAPID ACCESS TO
ADDICTION TREATMENT. SO A
PATIENT WHO'S SUFFERING FROM
OPIOID USE DISORDER COMES INTO
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT, AND WE
PROVIDE TREATMENT ON DEMAND THAT
VISIT, DESPITE BEING REALLY
DIFFICULT TO SAY, MEDICATIONS
LIKE BUPRENORPHINE AND
NALTREXONE ARE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
AND HAVE SHOWN TO INCREASE
RECOVERY RATES, DECREASE
OVERDOSE DEATH. WHAT THIS LOOKS
LIKE IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
IS SOMEONE WILL COME IN WITH AN
OVERDOSE. WE WILL REVERSE THE
OVERDOSE, BUT AT THAT POINT WE
ARE NOT DONE. AT THAT MOMENT. WE
NOW HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THAT PERSON INTO LONG TERM
TREATMENT. WE WILL START THEM ON
BUPRENORPHINE IN THAT ED VISIT
FOR MEDI-CAL, WHERE THERE IS NO
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION, WE WILL
SEND A PRESCRIPTION TO THE
PHARMACY AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT
PERSON HAS CONTINUOUS ACCESS TO
BUPRENORPHINE. BUPRENORPHINE
PREVENTS WITHDRAWAL AND HELPS
THAT PATIENT STOP USING. WHAT
HAPPENS IF YOU HAVE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE? YOU MIGHT GO TO THE
PHARMACY, BUMP INTO A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION, AND THAT
PRESCRIPTION IS NO LONGER
FILLED, RIGHT? THEN THE PATIENT
WILL GO BACK INTO WITHDRAWAL AND
POTENTIALLY START USING AN
OVERDOSE AGAIN. SO IN THIS
INSTANCE, LITERALLY HAVING THOSE
DELAYS, EVEN IF THEY ARE SHORT
AND TEMPORARY, WE LOSE PATIENTS
IN THAT PERIOD WHERE THEY GO
BACK INTO WITHDRAWAL AND WE ARE
UNABLE TO GET THEM INTO
TREATMENT. WE HAVE TO WAIT OFTEN
UNTIL THEY OVERDOSE AND COME
BACK AND THEN RESTART. SO ALL OF
THAT WORK IS LOST EVEN WITH A
SHORT DELAY. AND FOR THIS REASON
WE'RE ASKING TO REMOVE THAT
DELAY AND PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FOR THE COMMERCIALLY INSURED
PATIENT POPULATION. HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
MA'AM. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TIM MADDEN, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT, PLEASE. MITCH STEIGER
WITH CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS, IS
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SIR
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS.
MARK FAROOQ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. CHRISTINE SMITH, HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SIR. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS,
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY, AND THE
CITY OF COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO,
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
SEEING YOU. THANKS FOR JOINING
US. NEXT, PLEASE. JOHN DREBINGER
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, BRANDON MAKI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
PLEASE. AMMAR RASHID WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, LET'S TURN
TO WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
FIRST LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, IF ANY. YOU MAY TAKE
THE TABLE IF YOU'D LIKE.
HI. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, ROBERT
BOYKIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS.
REGRETTABLY, HERE TODAY, IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1842. THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. A
HEALTH PLANS HAVE HEARD THE
CONCERNS AND ARE CONSTANTLY
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS WHILE PROTECTING
PATIENTS AND DELIVERING HIGH
QUALITY CARE. HOWEVER, THIS BILL
SEEKS TO PROHIBIT HEALTH PLANS
FROM REQUIRING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION, THÀNH, OR STEP
THERAPY FOR SEVERAL DRUGS WHEN
TREATING SOMEONE WITH A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. FROM OUR
VIEWPOINT, UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT IS NECESSARY FOR
PATIENT SAFETY AND COST
EFFECTIVE CARE. FURTHER MORE,
THIS BILL IS LARGELY UNCHANGED
FROM LAST YEAR'S AB 1288, WHICH
THE GOVERNOR VETOED LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION, STATING
UTILIZATION REVIEW IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR CONTAINING
HEALTH CARE COSTS, PROTECTING
PATIENTS FROM UNANTICIPATED
BILLING, AND ENSURING MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE. UNFORTUNATELY,
AB 1842 DOES NOT ADDRESS ANY OF
THOSE. THOSE POINTS RAISED IN
THE VETO. BUT WITH THAT SAID, WE
ARE HARD AT WORK ON SOME
POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS THAT MAY
MOVE OUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE, ON A
POSSIBLE RESOLUTION, BUT FOR
THOSE REASONS STATED EARLIER, WE
ARE REGRETTABLY OPPOSED TO AB
1840. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US,
SIR. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE, PLEASE? MR.
CHAIR MEMBERS. JOHN WENGER, ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS, WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS THAT CAP LOOK FORWARD
TO FUTURE CONVERSATIONS.
SCHWINGER NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR MEMBERS MATT AIKEN WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH CAPTAIN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, LET'S
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
DAIS. COLLEAGUE. ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IT'S YOUR
LUCKY DAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU. I THINK
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY REMOVED
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FOR OUR
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS. THERE ARE
ALSO 17 STATES THAT HAVE LIMITED
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION. WE ARE
ASKING FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
AND ALSO, I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE, THERE WAS TALK ABOUT
FRAUDULENT REQUESTS OR ABUSE OF
DRUGS, AND SPECIFICALLY CALLED
OUT METHADONE. METHADONE IS NO
LONGER INCLUDED IN THIS BILL.
AND THAT WAS IN RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE. WE ARE,
IN ESSENCE, ASKING THAT YOU HELP
US STOP THE DELAYS AND SAVE
LIVES. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WHEN
WE AS SOON AS WE HAVE ONE, WE'LL
TAKE THE MOTION. WE'LL TAKE THE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU. NEXT
ITEM UP IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1977. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE,
BEHAVIORAL DIAGNOSES. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL, 1977,
WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES DON'T FACE BARRIERS
TO THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT THEY NEED. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WITH CLARIFY THAT HEALTH PLAN,
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REVIEW A
PATIENT TREATMENT PLAN AS
SPECIFIC UNDER CURRENT LAW. AB
1977 IS A RESULT OF CONVERSATION
WITH PARENTS OF CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM. DESPITE AUTISM BEING A
LIFELONG CONDITION, INSURANCE
COMPANIES OFTEN REQUIRE CONSTANT
REEVALUATION EVERY TWO YEARS IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. THIS REASSESSMENT IS
AN EXTENSION OF PROCESS
INVOLVING A BACKGROUND
QUESTIONNAIRE, INTERVIEW, AND
DIAGNOSTIC TEST WHICH CAN BE
VERY TRAUMATIC FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH AUTISM. THIS BURDENS THIS
BURDENSOME PROCESS, OFTEN
RESULTING IN DELAY OR EVEN
DENIALS FOR NECESSARY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. IT IS
DEADLINES ARE NOT MET. SEVERAL
HEALTH PLANS OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA REQUIRE NEW AUTISM
DIAGNOSIS EVERY TWO YEARS. IN
ORDER TO. FOR PATIENTS TO
RECEIVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. THIS IS REQUIRED
REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER OF
WHETHER A PATIENT HAS THE
VARIOUS AGNOSIS GIVEN THAT
AUTISM IS A LIFELONG CONDITION,
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO REQUIRE
CONSTANT RE DIAGNOSIS EVERY 2 TO
3 YEARS IN ORDER FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO RECEIVE NECESSARY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT, AB 1977 WOULD
PUT AN END TO THIS OUTDATED
PRACTICE AND PROHIBIT A HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLAN FROM REQUIRING
AN ENROLLEE PREVIOUSLY DIAGNOSED
WITH PERVASIVE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISORDER OF AUTISM FROM NEEDING
TO RECEIVE A NEW BEHAVIORAL
DIAGNOSIS TO MAINTAIN COVERAGE
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
WE HAVE TAKEN REASONABLE
AMENDMENT TO AB 1977 TO CLARIFY
THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT
RESTRICT OR TREAT PROVIDERS FROM
REEVALUATING AND ENROLLING TO
UPDATE THEIR TREATMENT PLAN. I'M
HONORED TO INTRODUCE MY WITNESS
ON THIS BILL, DOCTOR ANDREW
DAVIS, ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION, AND
DANIEL SAVINO FROM ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCY. THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD. FIRST, PLEASE. I'M
DOCTOR ANDREA DAVIS, AND I'M
WANTING TO THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROTH AND ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR SERVICE. I AM A
LICENSED PSYCHOLOGIST. I HOLD
INTERNATIONAL CERTIFICATIONS IN
AUTISM AND DIAGNOSIS AND
THERAPIES. I'M THE CHAIR ELECT
OF DIVISION ONE CALIFORNIA PSYCH
ASSOCIATION AND PRESIDENT OF THE
DIR. FLOORTIME COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA I OAN A LARGE GROUP
PRACTICE IN PASADENA. GREENHOUSE
THERAPY CENTER, WHERE WE
DIAGNOSE AUTISM AS PART OF OUR
WORK. THIS BILL, THOUGH,
PRIORITIZES PATIENT INTERESTS
OVER BUSINESS INTERESTS. THE
DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM REQUIRES
OBSERVATION, INTERVIEWING, AND
ADMINISTERING A WHOLE VARIETY OF
1 TO 1 TESTING PROTOCOLS BY A
PSYCHOLOGIST OR A PHYSICIAN.
THESE ARE OUR DETAILED
OBSERVATION PROTOCOLS REQUIRING
SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
CREDENTIALS AND CERTIFICATIONS,
NOT JUST ONE TEST. SO THIS TAKES
1 TO 2 DAYS OF TO COMPLETE ALL
THE ASSESSMENT OF IQ LANGUAGE,
BEHAVIOR, SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT,
ATTENTION AND LEARNING. SO YOU
SEE WHY IT'S HARD FOR FAMILIES
JUST TO GET A SLOT ON THE
SCHEDULE FOR THIS. AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW STRESSFUL THESE
TESTING DAYS ARE FOR CHILDREN,
ESPECIALLY AUTISTIC CHILDREN. IT
THEN REQUIRES 10 TO 20 MORE
HOURS OF PARENT AND TEACHER
INTERVIEWING, SCHOOL AND MEDICAL
RECORDS, REVIEW COMPLEX TEST
RESULTS, INTERPRETATION, AND TO
JUSTIFY THE CONCLUSIONS TO WRITE
A 20 TO 60 PAGE REPORT. A FORMAL
ASSESSMENT REPORT, AND THAT IS
REQUIRED BY ALL THE HEALTH PLANS
TO BEGIN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR AUTISM. BUT THE
WAIT LIST FOR THIS DIAGNOSTIC
PROCESS ARE ARE 6 TO 12 MONTHS
LONG. AND OF COURSE, MOST
FAMILIES CAN'T AFFORD 3 TO
$12,000 OUT OF POCKET FOR SUCH A
PROCESS, SO THEY'RE FORCED TO BE
ON EVEN LONGER WAIT LISTS FOR
TESTING PROVIDERS WHO ARE IN
NETWORK LIKE OURSELVES, OR THEY
CAN'T FIND SOMEBODY IN NETWORK.
SO AUTISTIC CHILDREN ARE BLOCKED
RIGHT AT THE OUTSET OF TREATMENT
BY THESE HUGE BARRIERS OF COSTS
AND WAIT LISTS. THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO WAIT. THE CDC AND
RESEARCH SAYS EARLY INTERVENTION
IS HOW THEY ACHIEVE BEST
OUTCOMES RIGHT. AND AUTISM, AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS SAID, IS
A LIFELONG DIAGNOSIS. SO I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I VOTE
TO STOP THE UNNECESSARY DO OVERS
OF A COSTLY AND STRESSFUL AND
LENGTHY BARRIER TO TREATMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US, SIR. YOU'RE
NEXT. DANIEL SAVINO, ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES, AS
THE LEAD WITNESS JUST INDICATED,
GETTING THAT INITIAL AUTISM
DIAGNOSIS TAKES A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME AND EFFORT ON THE
PART OF FAMILIES. IT'S A MAJOR,
MAJOR BARRIER. ONCE YOU HAVE
THAT, THEN THERE'S A TREATMENT
PLAN AND YOU WORK FORWARD FROM
THERE. BUILDING ON BEST
PRACTICES AND EXISTING SKILLS
AND WORK TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CHILD TO
ATTAIN THEIR BEST DEVELOPMENTAL
OUTCOMES. THAT PLAN NECESSARILY
CHANGES OVER TIME AS WE GROW,
OUR NEEDS CHANGE. THE DIAGNOSIS
DOES NOT. QUITE SIMPLY, A
DIAGNOSIS IS NOT NEEDED. IT'S
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE, AND IT'S A
WAY OF CREATING A BARRIER THAT,
AS WAS ESTABLISHED INITIALLY, IS
TREMENDOUS. IT'S NOT MEDICALLY
RECOMMENDED. THERE'S NO BASIS
FOR THAT. SO CERTAINLY VERY
REASONABLE THAT A TREATMENT PLAN
BE PROVIDED TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANY UPON REQUEST. THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED
ARE CERTAINLY VERY REASONABLE,
PROTECT THE NEEDS OF THE
INSURANCE COMPANY TO MONITOR
PROGRESS, BUT ALSO PROTECTS THE
NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING THESE SERVICES AND THE
FAMILIES FROM POTENTIALLY LOSING
ACCESS TO THOSE SERVICES BECAUSE
OF THE BARRIER THAT A
REDIAGNOSIS WOULD CREATE. I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IN THE HEARING
ROOM? PLEASE STEP FORWARD. NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY. PLEASE YES, MA'AM.
HELLO. CHRISTINA TAPIA, FAMILY
ADVOCATE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US NEXT, SIR. THANK YOU. DYLAN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SIR. RICK
ROLLINS, ON BEHALF OF THE AUTISM
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL, AS WELL. I'M A
PARENT OF A 35 YEAR OLD SON WITH
AUTISM. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US. YES, SIR. ALBERT CAMACHO
WITH A I'M A GRANDPARENT OF A
CHILD WITH AUTISM, AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. YES, MA'AM. HOLLY BENINCASA
WITH THE QUALIFIED APPLIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS CREDENTIALING
BOARD IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM. MARCELLA CASTANOS
HERE FROM A CHANGE IN
TRAJECTORY, ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, IRENE NAVA. WITH THE
CHANGE IN TRAJECTORY ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US. YES, SIR. NICHOLAS STOESSEL
BEHAVIORAL PROVIDER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BRANDON MAKI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN
PRINT. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU. MELISSA
CORTEZ, ON BEHALF OF AUTISM
SPEAKS AND THE COUNCIL OF AUTISM
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. PENNY SCHENKEN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HI. ERIC LINDER, REPRESENTING
QUALIFIED APPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSTS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOOD TO SEE YOU
BACK. YES, SIR. JANELLE SOSA, ON
BEHALF OF AUTISM BEHAVIOR
SERVICES. AND AS A PARENT, I
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM. ANDREA CASTRO IN
SUPPORT, ESPECIALLY AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS A BROTHER WHO HAS
AUTISM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM? SEEING NONE
. LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION, IF ANY. FIRST LEAD
OPPOSITION. COME ON DOWN.
OKAY. IF YOU'D IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD. AND
THEN YOU MAY START WHEN YOU'RE
READY, ONCE AGAIN, GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, ROBERT BOYKIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS REGRETTABLY
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED, TO AB
1977, WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR OF THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
FOR ENGAGING WITH US IN
CONVERSATIONS ON THE ISSUE AND
APPRECIATE THE OVERARCHING
INTENT OF THE BILL, AS THE
PAYERS AND HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM, WE HAVE UNIQUE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
PREMIUM DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
IN THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY
POSSIBLE, AND THAT OFTENTIMES
INCLUDES CONDUCTING PERIODIC
EVALUATIONS OF THE TREATMENT
PLANS, TO ENSURE OUR ENROLLEES
ARE RECEIVING THE MOST
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF CARE. WE
FEEL THE BILL AS DRAFTED REMOVES
THAT ABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
PEOPLE BEING TREATED FOR PDD OR
AUTISM, FOR THAT REASON, WE'RE
OPPOSED. WE ARE OPPOSED TO,
UNLESS AMENDED ON AB 1977. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT AIKEN WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES,
REGRETTABLY WITH AN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON
ASSEMBLY BILL 1977. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR, SPONSORS, COMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL, WE'VE HAD SOME VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS, AND
ALTHOUGH WE ARE CERTAINLY
SENSITIVE TO THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL, WE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
CAP SPECIFIC. WE WERE CONCERNED
THAT IT'S WRITTEN THIS BILL
COULD BE INTERPRETED TO PROHIBIT
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS FROM
REEVALUATING PATIENTS TREATMENT
PLANS, WHICH COULD HARM PATIENTS
QUALITY OF CARE. GIVEN THAT
PROVIDERS ARE STATUTORILY
REQUIRED TO REVIEW THE TREATMENT
PLAN, NO LESS THAN ONCE EVERY
SIX MONTHS, WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT HEALTH PLANS ARE
CLEARLY PERMITTED TO CONTINUE
EVALUATING TREATMENT PLANS AS
WELL. FOR THESE REASONS, WE ARE
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED ON
ASSEMBLY BILL 1977. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR AND STAFF IF THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR. THANK
YOU SIR. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM?
NAME AFFILIATION. POSITION,
PLEASE. CHAIR. MEMBERS. JOHN
WINGER, ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS, WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF CAP, AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS, BUT CURRENTLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU FOR
ATTENDING, SIR. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SEEING NONE COLLEAGUES
BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? YES, SIR.
SENATOR MENGIBAR, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MR. CHAIR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I'M GOING
TO BE CASTING MY I VOTE TODAY
FOR MY FOUR YEAR OLD NIECE WHO'S
AUTISTIC. AND I KNOW THE BURDEN
THAT MY SISTER HAS TO GO
THROUGH. AND JUST THE CONSTANT,
ENDLESS AMOUNT OF TESTING,
REAUTHORIZATION APPROVALS AND SO
FORTH. SO I'M GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BRING SOME
REPRIEVE TO THEM IN THIS PROCESS
. THANK YOU. SENATOR. SO
REMEMBER, YOU MAY CLOSE, ONCE
AGAIN, I ONE OF THE THINGS OUR
COMMITTEES, COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND
REALLY, REALLY PATIENT WORK WITH
MY OFFICE REALLY, REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SIR, AS SOON AS WE,
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND TAKE A VOTE. GOOD
PRESENTATION. YOU'RE UP NEXT
WITH ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 2449.
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROVIDERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AS WELL AS ONE OF
THE THINGS THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AB 2449, WOULD CLARIFY THAT THE
QUALIFIED APPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS CREDENTIAL BOARD IS A
NATIONAL ENTITY THAT MAY CERTIFY
A QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROVIDER AND AUTHORIZE THE
CERTIFICATION TO BE ACCREDITED
BY THE SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. THE QUALIFIED APPLIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS BOARD, OR
COBRA, WAS ESTABLISHED IN 2012
AND IS AN AGENCY WHOSE MISSION
IS TO ESTABLISH HIGHEST STANDARD
OF CARE AND EMPOWER OUR
PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE
BEHAVIORAL CARE TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH AUTISM. QUOBBA IS A SECOND
LARGEST CERTIFYING BODY FOR
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS IN THE
US AND THE LARGEST
INTERNATIONALLY, WHEREBY
CERTIFICATION OF VITAL TO THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN STATES WITH LARGE
MILITARY POPULATIONS AS MILITARY
BASES RECOGNIZE WABA FOR THE
LICENSES OF AUTISM SERVICE
PROVIDER, OUR STATE IS SEEING AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM,
RESULTING IN A SHORTAGE OF
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROVIDERS, PARTICULARLY IN LOW
INCOME AND MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. AB 2449 SEEKS TO
MEET THIS SHORTAGE OF
PROFESSIONAL CAREGIVERS BY
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL LICENSING
ORGANIZATION THAT IS RECOGNIZED
FEDERALLY AND WORLDWIDE FOR
THEIR HIGH STANDARD. IT WILL
EFFECTIVELY END CALIFORNIA
RELIANCE ON A SINGLE ENTITY TO
PROVIDE ALL CERTIFICATION BY
CREATING COMPETITION IN THE
FIELD. I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
NATALIE COOPER, WHO IS A PARENT,
ADVOCATE AND JASMINE GUTIERREZ,
WHO IS LITIGATION. PLEASE PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS NATALIE COOPER, AND I'M
HERE TODAY BOTH AS A PARENT OF A
CHILD WITH AUTISM AND A PARENT
ADVOCATE WHO ASSISTS OTHER
FAMILIES NAVIGATING SIMILAR
CHALLENGES, I STAND BEFORE YOU
TO EXPRESS MY UNWAVERING SUPPORT
FOR AB 2449 FOR THE PAST 14
YEARS SEEMS UNBELIEVABLE. MY SON
HAS BENEFITED IMMENSELY FROM
APPLIED BEHAVIORAL ANALYSIS
THERAPY THIS THERAPY HAS BEEN
ADMINISTERED BY TEAM MEMBERS
CERTIFIED THROUGH THE QUALIFIED
APPLIED BEHAVIORAL ANALYSIS
CREDENTIALING BOARD. THE IMPACT
ON MY SON'S DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN
NOTHING SHORT OF LIFE CHANGING.
HIS PROGRESS IN COMMUNICATING
THÀNH, SOCIALIZATION AND DAILY
LIVING SKILLS HAD OPENED DOORS
WE ONCE THOUGHT WERE CLOSED.
PARENTS OF CHILDREN WITH AUTISM
SHOULD HAVE THE AUTONOMY TO
CHOOSE THE PRACTITIONERS WHO
PROVIDE THESE CRUCIAL SERVICES.
THE SUCCESS OF OUR CHILDREN'S
TREATMENT HINGES ON THE
QUALIFICATIONS AND THE PERSON
CENTERED APPROACH OF THEIR
CAREGIVERS. AB 2449 ACKNOWLEDGES
THIS NEED BY RECOGNIZING THE
HIGH STANDARDS AND RIGOROUS
CERTIFICATION PROCESS OF THE ABA
. IT'S NOT JUST MY FAMILY THAT
STANDS TO BENEFIT THE CALIFORNIA
AUTISM SOCIETY AND ITS LOCAL
CHAPTERS, INCLUDING THE LOS
ANGELES SOCIETY, ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF QUÊ ABA
CERTIFIED PROFESSIONALS MEET THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS AND CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESS CURRENT
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, PARTICULARLY AMONG
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
MANY FAMILIES ARE STUCK ON
WAITLISTS DUE TO LACK OF
QUALIFIED PROVIDERS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TROUBLING WHEN WE
HAVE PRACTITIONERS ALREADY
RECOGNIZED IN OTHER STATES WHO
COULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE EVERY DAY
THAT A CHILD WITH AUTISM GOES
WITHOUT THERAPY IS A DAY LOST
OPPORTUNITY FOR GROWTH AND
SUCCESS. BY SUPPORTING AB 2449,
YOU HAVE THE POWER TO EXPAND THE
DIVERSITY AND ABILITY OF SKILLED
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA,
ENSURING MORE CHILDREN RECEIVE
THE HELP THEY DESPERATELY NEED
IN CONCLUSION, I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 2449 AND GIVE ALL
FAMILIES THE CHANCE TO CHOOSE
HIGHLY QUALIFIED, QUÊ ABA
CERTIFIED PRACTITIONERS FOR
THEIR CHILDREN IN OUR CHILDREN'S
FUTURES DEPEND ON IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. NEXT,
PLEASE. JASMINE GUTIERREZ, MY
NAME IS JASMINE GUTIERREZ AND I
AM HERE REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY OF MERCED, CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE DEDICATED MY CAREER TO
THE FIELD OF APPLIED BEHAVIORAL
ANALYSIS, WITH A PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON SERVING INDIVIDUALS
WITH AUTISM. THE TREATMENT THESE
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE IS CRUCIAL
FOR THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND
QUALITY OF LIFE, AND IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO PROVIDERS WHO ARE THE BEST
SUITED TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. I
BEGAN MY JOURNEY IN THIS FIELD
IN 2020, EARNING MY BEHAVIOR
TECHNICIAN CERTIFICATION THROUGH
THE QUALIFIED APPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS CREDENTIALING CUABA.
OVER TIME, IT ADVANCED TO BECOME
AN ASSISTANT BEHAVIOR ANALYST,
ACHIEVING CERTIFICATION AS A
CLASS ALSO THROUGH COBA. MY
TRAINING WITH COBA HAS BEEN
INVALUABLE, PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
IT EMPHASIZES PERSON CENTERED
VALUES, AUTISM, KNOWLEDGE AND
COMPREHENSIVE ABA TECHNIQUES.
HOWEVER, I ENCOUNTERED A
SIGNIFICANT HURDLE WHEN I
ASPIRED TO ADVANCE FURTHER. THE
COBA CERTIFICATION IS NOT
CURRENTLY RECOGNIZED AT THE
MASTER'S LEVEL WITHIN OUR STATE
STATUTE, COMPELLING ME TO SWITCH
TO THE BACB CERTIFICATION. THIS
TRANSITION, WHILE NECESSARY
UNDER CURRENT REGULATIONS, DOES
NOT REFLECT MY STRONG BELIEF IN
THE PRINCIPLES AND TRAINING
OFFERED BY COBA. THE DIVERSITY
OF MY COMMUNITY IS MIRRORED IN
MY PROFESSIONAL JOURNEY. JUST AS
I SPEAK SPANISH AND PROVIDE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT, CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CARE TO MY CLIENTS, I
BELIEVE THAT PROFESSIONALS IN
OUR FIELD SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO CHOOSE THE CERTIFICATION THAT
BEST ALIGNS WITH THEIR TRAINING
AND VALUES. THE INCLUSION OF
COBA IN OUR STATE STATUTES WOULD
NOT ONLY VALIDATE THE RIGOROUS
AND SPECIALIZED TRAINING IT
PROVIDES, BUT ALSO SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DIVERSITY AND
CHOICE. THEREFORE, I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER CONSIDER THE INCLUSION
OF IN OUR STATE CERTIFICATION
STATUTES SUCH A DECISION WOULD
EMPOWER PROFESSIONALS LIKE
MYSELF TO CONTINUE DELIVERING
HIGH QUALITY, PERSON CENTERED
CARE TAILORED TO THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
NORMALLY WE ALLOW TWO WITNESSES.
I SEE THAT I HAVE FOUR IN FRONT
OF ME. WE'RE JUST HERE FOR
EXPERT TESTIMONY. THAT'S IT. OR
REQUEST TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US, MA'AM. AND
AGAIN, GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
LIKEWISE, SENATOR. ALWAYS A
PLEASURE. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE,
PLEASE. HI. MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
TAPIA, FAMILY ADVOCATE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER WHO WAITED THREE
YEARS FOR AUTISM SERVICES IN
EAST PALO ALTO, CALIFORNIA DUE
TO LACK OF PROVIDERS. SO I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. OKAY. NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY. PLEASE. PLEASE
PROCEED. MA'AM DOCTOR ANDREA
DAVIS, DIR. FLOORTIME COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA AND GREEN HOUSE
THERAPY CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR STAYING. MARCELLA
CASTANOS. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
CLINICAL OPERATIONS AT AN AGENCY
THAT PROVIDES SERVICES FOR KIDS
WITH AUTISM AND SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI,
IRENE NAVA FROM A CHANGING
TRAJECTORY AS WELL, THE LEAD
PROGRAM COORDINATOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. YES, SIR.
NICHOLAS ALSO A BACB BOARD
MEMBER, BUT STILL IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. MAGDA LENA CAMACHO IN
SUPPORT WITH AB 2449. SINCE I
HAVE A GRANDSON WHO IS AUTISTIC.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. FOR
SCHWAB, I'M A FAMILY ADVOCATE OF
AB 2449 WITH THREE AUTISTIC
SIBLINGS WHO HAVE ABA SERVICES.
THANK YOU. YES SIR. JANELLE SOSA
I'M COMING FROM SAN BERNARDINO
AREA ON BEHALF OF AUTISM
SERVICES. AND AS A PARENT, WITH
A KID WITH AUTISM, I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. I'M MARIANA GARCIA. I'M
A S I'M AT AUTISM BEHAVIOR
SERVICES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. YES,
PLEASE, I'M ASHLYN HAWK. I AM A
PARENT OF A CHILD WITH AUTISM,
AND I'M IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YES, SIR. HELLO. MY NAME IS JUAN
LOPEZ. I HAVE TWO KIDS. AUTISM I
SUPPORT THE BILL. AB 2449. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. MY
NAME IS JESSICA HERNANDEZ. TENGO
DOS HIJOS CON AUTISMO E APOYO AL
BEALL, AB VEINTICUATRO NUEVE.
OKAY. HER NAME IS JESSICA
HERNANDEZ, AND SHE HAS TWO KIDS
WITH AUTISM, AND SHE SUPPORTS
THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US. YES, SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TYLER WINDY,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT, THANK YOU. HI.
ALBERT CAMACHO AGAIN, A
GRANDPARENT OF A CHILD WITH
AUTISM. AND I REPRESENT ALSO THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER MONTH.
I'M FROM THE ISLAND OF SAIPAN
AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR COMING. YES,
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS MARIA ALDAMA AND I HAVE A SIX
YEAR OLD WITH AUTISM, AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS SELENA
FRAZIER. I'M THE PARENT OF A
CHILD WITH AUTISM, AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. HI, I'M
KAREN CAPRA. I'M THE SINGLE
PARENT OF A CHILD WITH AUTISM,
AND I FULLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR JOINING
US. YES, MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS VERONICA PRECIADO,
AND I AM THE PARENT OF A SEVEN
YEAR OLD WITH AUTISM. AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. YES, SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME, SERGIO
PRECIADO, AND CAME FROM MODESTO,
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE A SON WITH
AUTISM. AND THANK YOU FOR HEAR
US AND THANK YOU FOR HELPING US
WITH THIS BILL. THANK YOU. YES,
SIR, RICK ROLLINS, ON BEHALF OF
THE AUTISM BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM. BUENAS TARDES. MY
NAME IS GUADALUPE TAMAYO. SOY
MADRE DE UN NINO CON AUTISMO E
APOYO LÀ LÀ A VEINTICUATRO NUEVE
. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. YES,
MA'AM, ANDREA CASTRO, SIBLING TO
A CHILD WITH AUTISM, IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM? LET'S TURN
TO WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION. ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
FIRST, YOU MAY JOIN US AT THE
TABLE.
IF YOU'D INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD AND THEN PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU, I WILL
START, MELISSA CORTEZ HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL OF AUTISM
SERVICE PROVIDERS, CASP IS A
NONPROFIT TRADE ASSOCIATION OF
AUTISM SERVICE PROVIDER
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTED TO
PROMOTING AND DELIVERING
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM. CAS
REPRESENTS 54 CALIFORNIA BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SERVING THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN AND ADULTS ON THE
AUTISM SPECTRUM. CASP IS NOT
ANTI-CUBA OR PRO BCBA. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT COBA AND OTHER
CERTIFYING ENTITIES ARE INTENDED
TO SUPPORT THE AUTISM COMMUNITY
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS. CASP IS NOT
OPPOSED TO RECOGNIZING THE
MID-TIER CASP S OR THE ENTRY
LEVEL ABATE CREDENTIAL, AS THEY
ARE SUPERVISED BY QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROVIDER. HOWEVER
LOWERING THE PROVIDER
CREDENTIALING STANDARDS FOR
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROVIDERS WHO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT TREATMENT PLANS PLACES
CONSUMERS AT RISK. ANY NEW
CREDENTIALING CONSIDERED SHOULD
BE, SHOULD MEET OR EXCEED THE
CURRENT CRITERIA FOR
CERTIFICATION. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE AND ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE ABSENCE OF
LICENSURE IN THIS STATE, WHERE
THERE IS NO STATE OVERSIGHT FOR
THESE PROVIDERS. COBAS QUALIFIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS, OR QBA
CREDENTIAL LACKS SUFFICIENT
EDUCATIONAL AND EXPERIENTIAL
LEARNING REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE
COMPETENCE IN THE PRACTICE OF
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS. THIS
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SCIENTIFIC
UNDERPINNINGS OF THE STUDY OF
BEHAVIOR AND SUFFICIENT
SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE COMPETENCE
TO ENSURE NO HARM TO SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
CITIZENS. CHILDREN WITH AUTISM.
TO OUR KNOWLEDGE, THE QBA IS
ONLY RECOGNIZED IN ONE OTHER
STATE. OF THE 843 ACTIVE COBA
CERTIFICANTS IN CALIFORNIA, ONLY
23 ARE QBS AND ONLY SIX OF THOSE
23 DO NOT HAVE THEIR BCBA OR
BCBA D THE CERTIFICATION THAT'S
ALREADY RECOGNIZED IN STATUTE,
THE QBA CREDENTIAL, HAS BEEN
PROPOSED FOR LICENSURE IN TEXAS,
GEORGIA, VIRGINIA, NEVADA,
KANSAS, WASHINGTON, OKLAHOMA,
AND OREGON. EACH LICENSING BOARD
HAS INDICATED THAT THEY WILL NOT
CHANGE THEIR LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS CGRTS AND WILL NOT
INCLUDE THE QBA, CITING
EDUCATIONAL AND EXPERIENTIAL
CONCERNS. CASP SUPPORTS THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE NATIONAL
COMMISSION FOR CERTIFYING
AGENCIES AND CA ACCREDITATION.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH EVERY
OTHER HEALTH CARE CERTIFICATION
IN THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE. WE WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
FOR THE AMENDMENT AND THANK THE
STAFF FOR THAT AS WELL, HOWEVER,
WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL TODAY. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE AMENDMENT DOES IMPROVE THE
BILL, BUT WE REMAIN OPPOSED AND
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MICHELLE
HYDE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BEHAVIORAL ANALYSIS, I AM A
BOARD CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYST
AND ALSO A PARENT OF A CHILD ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM. KALABAW IS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB 2449
AS IT CONTRADICTS WIDELY
ACCEPTED STANDARDS AND BEST
PRACTICES IN CREDENTIALING AND
OVERSIGHT OF PRACTITIONERS IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. KALABAW IS THE
NONPROFIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE OVER 29,000
PRACTITIONERS OF APPLIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS IN OUR STATE.
OUR CONCERNS REGARDING THE
ADDITION OF THE CERTIFY CGRTS TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATUTE, AS
PROPOSED IN AB 2449, ARE
TWOFOLD. AS WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT COBA AS AN ENTITY AS WELL
AS THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THEIR
CERTIFICATION. AS CURRENTLY,
STATUTE DEFINES A QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROVIDER AS A
PERSON WHO IS EITHER LICENSED BY
THE STATE IN ONE OF SEVERAL
PROFESSIONS OR CERTIFIED IN
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS BY THE
BEHAVIOR ANALYST CERTIFICATION
BOARD, WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WITH
WELL-ESTABLISHED AND RECOGNIZED
PROCEDURES FOR DEVELOPING
REQUIREMENTS AND ISSUING
CERTIFICATIONS. AT PRESENT,
THERE IS NO LICENSURE FOR
PRACTITIONERS OF BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS IN CALIFORNIA, AND THUS
ENFORCEMENT OF ETHICAL STANDARDS
IS ESSENTIAL FOR PROTECTING
CONSUMERS. LICENSURE FOR
BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS IN CALIFORNIA
IS A PRIORITY FOR KALABAW, AS IT
WOULD ENSURE CONSUMER
PROTECTION. THE BEHAVIOR ANALYST
CERTIFICATION BOARD OVERSEES THE
PRACTICE OF ITS CERTIFICATES. IT
HAS WELL-DEVELOPED ETHICS CODE
AND SPECIFIED PROCEDURES FOR
ENFORCING THE CODE WITH ITS
HOLDERS, WITH HOLDERS OF ITS
CERTIFICATIONS, INFORMATION
ABOUT REPORTING POSSIBLE
VIOLATIONS ARE READILY AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC ON THE WEBSITE,
ALONG WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
DISCIPLINARY ACTION TAKEN
AGAINST ITS CERTIFICATES.
OVERSIGHT OF ETHICAL CONDUCT OF
COBA CERTIFICATES IS DONE BY
THEIR BOARD IS DIFFICULT TO FIND
INFORMATION ON THE WEBSITE ABOUT
ITS ETHICS CODE. HOW IT WAS
DEVELOPED OR ENFORCED, AND THERE
IS NO INFORMATION ABOUT
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AVAILABLE
ON THE WEBSITE. THAT RAISES
SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
PROTECTION OF CONSUMERS WHO
RECEIVE SERVICES FROM COBA
CERTIFICANTS. IN ADDITION, THE
COBA CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY WEAKER THAN OTHER
PROGRAMS FOR LICENSING OR
CERTIFYING PRACTITIONERS IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS.
THEY CONTRAST WITH THOSE
PROGRAMS AND ENTITIES THAT
MANAGE THEM IN SEVERAL IMPORTANT
WAYS. ITS BYLAWS SHOWED THAT THE
COBA BOARD IS OWNED AND
CONTROLLED BY A PRIVATELY HELD
FOR PROFIT COMPANY. IT APPEARS
THAT THE COBA BOARD IS APPOINTED
BY THE PARENT COMPANY, AND NO
INFORMATION ABOUT COMPANY'S
OWNERS OR INVESTORS IS PROVIDED
ON THE WEBSITE OR IN ITS
DOCUMENTS. MOST NONPROFIT
PROFESSIONAL CERTIFYING ENTITIES
MAKE INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
GOVERNANCE, CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND HOW THOSE ARE
DEVELOPED AND OTHER STANDARDS
READILY AVAILABLE ON THEIR
WEBSITES. PARALLEL INFORMATION
IS UNAVAILABLE OR DIFFICULT TO
FIND ON THE QUBO WEBSITE.
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING BCBA
CERTIFICATION IN ABA MUST BE
COMPLETE. GRADUATE LEVEL
COURSEWORK FROM ACCREDITED
UNIVERSITIES. CANDIDATES FOR THE
COBA CERTIFICATION FOR
INDEPENDENT PRACTITIONERS
INSTEAD CAN TAKE TRAININGS FROM
PRIVATE VENDORS WHO ARE APPROVED
BY THE BOARD. CANDIDATES FOR
LICENSURE OR CERTIFICATION. IN
MOST PROFESSIONS MUST PASS A
PROFESSIONAL EXAM THAT IS
ADMINISTERED AT A SECURE TESTING
CENTER. CANDIDATES FOR THE ABA
CERTIFICATION CAN TAKE AN EXAM
IN THEIR HOME OR WORKPLACE
WORKPLACE THAT IS PROCTORED BY A
COMPANY EXAMINEE THAT HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF NUMEROUS
COMPLAINTS. MOST LICENSED AND
CERTIFICATIONS IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONS ARE IN THE
PRACTICE OF THAT PROFESSION.
GENERALLY, INFORMATION ON THE
WEBSITE INDICATES THAT CLEARLY
THAT THE COBA CERTIFICATION IS
IN AUTISM INTERVENTION RATHER
THAN THE PRACTICE OF ABA OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSION.
GENERALLY, WE RECOGNIZE AND
THANK THE CHAIR AND STAFF FOR
THE AMENDMENTS BEING PROPOSED.
HOWEVER ABA REMAINS STAUNCHLY
OPPOSED AS WE STRIVE TO ENSURE
THAT STATE LAWS AFFORD ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS FOR ALL CONSUMERS OF
ABA SERVICES. IF AB 2449 WERE
ADOPTED, IT WOULD PUT HEALTH
CARE BENEFICIARIES WITH AUTISM
AND THEIR FAMILIES AT RISK. IN
OUR VIEW, IT WOULD ALSO
UNDERMINE, UNDERMINE ALL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS IN
THE STATE AND BEYOND TO AVOID
THOSE PROBLEMS, WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON 2449
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE HEARING ROOM? IF SO,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY. PLEASE PENNY
SCHENKEN FROM SAN FRANCISCO, A
BOARD CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYST
IN OPPOSITION, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM?
SEEING NONE. LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SENATOR
MENGIBAR A QUESTION, MR. CHAIR,
TO THE OPPOSITION, I'M SORRY TO
THE SUPPORT. CAN YOU SHARE OR
SOME RESPONSE, THE LEVEL OF
TRAINING OR CERTIFICATION THAT
GOES INTO THE ONES YOU'RE
REPRESENTING HERE TODAY? OKAY I
CAN GO AHEAD AND ANSWER THAT. SO
FOR THE C¯ VÀ, IT REQUIRES 270
HOURS OF COURSEWORK, A MASTER'S
DEGREE FROM AN ACCREDITED
UNIVERSITY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION,
1500 HOURS OF FIELD WORK WITH 5%
SUPERVISION, 900 IS INDIRECT.
AND THEN, 600 IS DIRECT WITH THE
ACTUAL CLIENT. SO. SO MAYBE IF
THIS IS BOTH SO WHERE BECAUSE
THE OPPOSITION IS SAYING IT'S
LOWER TRAINING OR LESS TRAINING,
THEY IT WAS INCREASED FROM THE
OTHER BOARD IN 2022 TO 315
HOURS. BUT BEFORE THAT IT WAS
PARALLEL. HOWEVER, WE DO THERE'S
ONLY A COUPLE OF HOURS
DIFFERENCE OR NO, WHAT AM I
MISSING HERE? THE OPPOSITION'S
CHANGED THEIR, REQUIRED AMOUNT
OF HOURS AFTER WE ENTERED THE
MARKET. GOT IT. CAN I RESPOND AS
WELL? I WOULD LIKE TO. YEAH.
HERE SO ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR BC BCBA CERTIFICATION IS YOU
HAVE TO TAKE A UNIVERSITY
COURSEWORK, INCLUDING A MASTER'S
DEGREE, TO RECEIVE YOUR
CERTIFICATION. THE ABA INDICATES
ON THEIR WEBSITE THAT THEY
REQUIRE COURSEWORK FROM AN
APPROVED COURSE SEQUENCE THAT'S
APPROVED BY THEIR BOARD, IN
ADDITION TO A MASTER'S DEGREE.
BUT YOUR COURSEWORK AND BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS CAN BE TAKEN FROM A
THIRD PARTY VENDOR. THAT'S
APPROVED BY THEIR BOARD. WHERE
THE BACB REQUIRES UNIVERSITY
COURSEWORK. GOT IT. THANK YOU.
SO IS THE OPPOSITION SOLELY ON
THE DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN THE
TRAINING THAT GOES INTO OKAY, SO
WE ARE OPPOSED BASED ON THIS
BEING A LOWER STANDARD FOR BOTH
EXPERIENCE AND EDUCATION TO BE
CERTIFIED. WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS
WITH QUOBBA BEING A FOR PROFIT
ENTITY WHO DOES APPROVE THEIR
OWN COURSEWORK GENERALLY.
CERTIFYING ENTITIES ARE
NONPROFIT IN HEALTH CARE, RIGHT?
YEAH, I SAW THAT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. OKAY THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES, ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS OR CONCERNS?
SEEING NONE. SOME MEMBER YOU MAY
CLOSE. ONCE AGAIN, I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
PATIENTLY WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE. WE APPRECIATE THAT. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GIGABOT
AT SUCH TIME AS WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
A VOTE. NICE PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING US. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 8AB 2435.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. SIR. GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS SINCE 2012 COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAS ENGAGED IN A
PUBLIC PROCESS WITH ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WHEN
PROPOSING AND ADOPTING
REGULATORY CHANGES. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GRANTED COVERED
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY RULEMAKING
AUTHORITY BECAUSE THEY MUST ACT
FASTER THAN THE TRADITIONAL
RULEMAKING PROCESS ALLOWS TO
IMPLEMENT CHANGES IN LAWS THAT
AFFECT HEALTH CARE ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS. THIS EMERGENCY
AUTHORITY EXPIRES ON JANUARY
1ST, 2025. CONSUMERS WILL BE AT
RISK OF SIGNIFICANT DELAY OF NEW
BENEFITS OR PROTECTIONS IF
COVERED. CALIFORNIA IS NOT ABLE
TO QUICKLY CONFORM TO NEW STATE
AND FEDERAL POLICY. THEY HAVE
COVERED CALIFORNIA'S RECENTLY
NEEDED, OR WILL SOON NEED TO
IMPLEMENT NEW SUBSIDIES TO HELP
MORE PEOPLE AFFORD HEALTH CARE.
CREATE A PROGRAM TO HELP WORKERS
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE, AND REVISING
REGULATIONS IN RESPONSE TO
FEDERAL CHANGES, AB 2435 WOULD
EXTEND COVERAGE. CALIFORNIA'S
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING PACKAGES UNTIL
JANUARY 1ST, 2030, IN ORDER TO
ADEQUATELY AND PROMPTLY REACT TO
BOTH ANNUAL AND ONGOING CHANGES
IN FEDERAL AND STATE RULES ONCE
THE EMERGENCY RULEMAKING PROCESS
HAS BEEN COMPLETED, COVERED,
CALIFORNIA MUST THEN COMPLETE
THE PERMANENT RULEMAKING PROCESS
WITHIN FIVE YEARS. THIS ALLOWS
FOR ANOTHER ROUND OF PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT THROUGH COMMENTS AT
BOARD MEETINGS AND THROUGH THE
REGULAR RULEMAKING PROCESS. BY
PASSING AB 2435. THIS ENSURES
COVERED CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO
SERVE CONSUMERS WHILE CONFORMING
TO NEW STATE AND FEDERAL
POLICIES. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS CHRISTINE SMITH FROM
HEALTH ACCESS AND KELLY GREEN
WITH COVERED CALIFORNIA IS ALSO
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD AND PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. CHRISTINE SMITH, THE
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU, WE ARE PLEASED TO BE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2435 HEALTH
ACCESS HAS TESTIFIED AT EVERY
SINGLE MEETING OF THE COVERED
CALIFORNIA BOARD SINCE IT BEGAN
MEETING IN 2011. EVERY MEETING
FROM THE BEGINNING COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A CUSTOM THAT
A TOPIC IS DISCUSSED AT ONE
PUBLIC MEETING AND THEN VOTED ON
A MONTH LATER AT A SUBSEQUENT
PUBLIC MEETING. THIS PRACTICE
MEANS THAT IF ANY INTERESTED
PARTY HAS CONCERNS ABOUT A
PROPOSED EMERGENCY REGULATION,
THEN THE BOARD HEARS THOSE
CONCERNS AND IN THE INTERVENING
MONTH, THE STAFF OF COVERED
CALIFORNIA CAN ATTEMPT TO
RESOLVE THOSE CONCERNS BEFORE
THE MATTER RETURNS TO THE BOARD.
IN ADDITION, COVERED CALIFORNIA
STAFF ROUTINELY MEETS WITH
INTERESTED PARTIES, INCLUDING
CONSUMER ADVOCATES WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC MEETINGS.
AB 2435 CONTINUES THE EXISTING
LAW REQUIRING THIS PUBLIC
PROCESS AND FACILITATING THE
INFORMAL PROCESS OF
CONSULTATION. WHILE WE ARE NOT
OVERALL FANS OF EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS, THIS PUBLIC PROCESS
AND THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT GIVES ANY INTERESTED
PARTY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US, KELLY GREEN,
ON BEHALF OF COVERED CALIFORNIA,
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US, MA'AM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE,
STARTING WITH LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. BRANDON MARTY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE HERE
REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION, WANT
TO START BY SAYING THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR, WHO IS ALSO MY
FORMER BOSS AND ONE OF MY VERY
GOOD COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS, AT
COVERED CALIFORNIA. I'VE DONE MY
BEST TO TEACH HIM, BUT WE WENT
TO THE DARK SIDE. HE WAS
STUBBORN TO SOME OF THE LESSONS,
BUT WE'LL CHAT AFTERWARDS. A
COUPLE OF THEM, OUR OPPOSITION
IS NOT NECESSARILY THAT WE
DISAGREE. THAT COVERED
CALIFORNIA SHOULD SHOULD HAVE
EMERGENCY RULE MAKING AUTHORITY
IN CASES OF TRUE EMERGENCIES. WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD. THE
BILL IS MUCH MORE EXPANSIVE
THAN, THAN TRUE EMERGENCIES. AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT TRUNCATED
TIMELINE, INHIBITS THE PUBLIC'S
ABILITY TO HAVE INPUT INTO
REGULATION, MAKING REGULATIONS.
IT INHIBITS, INTERESTED PARTIES
AND STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS CMA AND
OTHERS. BUT IT ALSO PROHIBITS
AND, PUTS BARRIERS IN FRONT OF
YOUR ABILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LAWS THAT YOU HAVE WORKED SO
HARD TO CRAFT AND PASS GET
IMPLEMENTED, AS YOU SAW THEM,
AND AS YOU CRAFTED THEM, SO
BASED OFF OF THOSE CONCERNS AND
JUST THE GENERAL PROLIFERATION
THAT WE HAVE SEEN, TO, TO THE
EXEMPTIONS TO THE APA PROCESS,
THROUGH IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS, WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, AND THANKS FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION? PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. SEEING NO WITNESSES,
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DESK. COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE. SOME MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE
JUST TO CLOSE ON THE COMMENTS,
MY GOOD FRIEND MR. MARKEY
BROUGHT UP, I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT, THE REGULATION ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS ENSURES THE PUBLIC IS
ACTUALLY PROVIDED AT LEAST THREE
OPPORTUNITIES TO REVIEW AND
COMMENT ON PROPOSED REGULATION.
THERE'S AMPLE TIME FOR
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENGAGE WITH
COVERED CALIFORNIA STAFF,
WHETHER IT'S TO FURTHER MODIFY
OR DEVELOP PROPOSED REGULATIONS
AND THEN, ONCE COVERED,
CALIFORNIA HAS COMPLETED THE
EMERGENCY RULEMAKING PROCESS.
THEY MUST THEN COMPLETE THE
PERMANENT RULEMAKING PROCESS
WITHIN FIVE YEARS. SO WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THE PUBLIC IS GOING TO HAVE
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY TO THIS.
IT'S IMPORTANT JUST BECAUSE THE
COMPLEXITY AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
COVERED, WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON ANY OF THOSE CONCERNS. BUT I
DID WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR TO
THE COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST, AND I VOTE
AT SUCH TIME AS WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. WE'LL TAKE A MOTION
AND WE WILL TAKE A VOTE.
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US.
AND THE FINAL ITEM ON THE AGENDA
IS ITEM NUMBER NINE, ASSEMBLY
BILL 2995, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON, WELCOME. GOOD TO HAVE
YOU HERE. THANK YOU, SIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, AB 2995, WHICH WOULD
MAKE CHANGES TO EXISTING LAW
REMOVING STIGMATIZING LANGUAGE
FOR PEOPLE SEEKING ALCOHOL OR
DRUG TREATMENT SERVICES. THE
BILL WOULD REPLACE OUTDATED
TERMINOLOGY WITH PERSON FIRST
LANGUAGE. AB 2995 CURRENTLY HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND
WITH ME TODAY IS OUR BILL
SPONSOR, DR, AMIR RASHID. ALL
RIGHT. ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR, HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION, TO SPEAK ON THE
IMPACT OF THIS BILL, SIR, PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND SENATORS, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. EXCUSE ME TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS AMMAR
RASHID, AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE LEADERS OF
THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES THAT SERVE THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER NEEDS OF THE MEDI-CAL
UNINSURED AND UNDERINSURED
POPULATIONS. CBH TODAY IS HERE.
TODAY IS A PROUD SUPPORTER AND
SPONSOR OF AB 2995, WHICH
MODERNIZES EXISTING LAW BY
REMOVING STIGMATIZING LANGUAGE
RELATED TO SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS AND ASSOCIATED
TREATMENTS AND SUBSTITUTES IT
WITH PERSON FIRST LANGUAGE,
WHERE APPROPRIATE. STIGMA
SURROUNDING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS IS PERVASIVE, A
REFLECTION OF SOCIETAL ATTITUDES
WHICH CAN LEAD TO AN ARRAY OF
HARMFUL IMPACTS, RESEARCH SHOWS
IT CAN LEAD TO INDIVIDUALS IN
NEED TO BE LESS LIKELY TO ACCESS
IMPORTANT AND LIFE SAVING, LIFE
SAVING SUD TREATMENT, OR DUE TO
STIGMATIZING LANGUAGE, BE LESS
LIKELY TO CONTINUE ON THEIR PATH
TO RECOVERY. STIGMA SURROUNDING
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER CAN LEAD
TO DISCRIMINATION IN OBTAINING
HOUSING, ACCESSING HEALTH
SERVICES AND TREATMENT, AS WELL
AS EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AB 2995 CHANGES
TACKLE STIGMA BY UPDATING
EXISTING LANGUAGE AND LAW TO
BETTER ALIGN WITH THE NON
STIGMATIZING PERSON. FIRST
LANGUAGE USED BY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL HELPS
CALIFORNIA TAKE ONE IMPORTANT
STEP TOWARDS ADDRESSING STIGMA
THROUGH MODERNIZING STATUTE. AS
WE CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE THE
MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL WELL-BEING
OF CALIFORNIANS, CBA THINKS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS
BILL AND RESPECTFULLY URGES YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE, PLEASE? THANK
YOU. CHAIR TRENT MURPHY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YES,
PLEASE COME ASHIGARA YOUTH
HEALTH ADVOCATE, HEALTH
EDUCATION STARTUP FOUNDER AND
PRE-MEDICAL STUDENT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU. YES
MA'AM, ANDREA CASTRO, STUDENT
WITH OVER PEER HEALTH EDUCATOR
WITH OVER EIGHT YEARS EXPERIENCE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? LET'S TURN
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FIRST, ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS THIS. DON'T SEE ANY OF
THOSE. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES OKAY. LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IT'S YOUR
LUCKY DAY. YOU MAY CLOSE. NO
OTHER COLLEAGUES HERE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN. I WILL
AS SOON AS WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE WILL GIVE YOU THAT.
THANK YOU. SIR NICE PRESENTATION
. OKAY, LET ME ASK FOR ALL
MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
WHO ARE NOT HERE TO PLEASE
REPORT TO THE HEARING ROOM SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND TAKE
MOTIONS AND TAKE VOTES ON THESE
MEASURES AS.
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE WILL
BE IN RECESS FOR TEN MINUTES.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
WILL RECONVENE. LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. SENATOR ROTH HERE.
ROTH HERE. WHEN? HERE. WHEN
HERE. GLASER. GLASER HERE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. HERE.
HURTADO YES. HURTADO. HERE.
LIMÓN MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. HERE.
RUBIO PRESENT. RUBIO. PRESENT.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER. YEAH.
THAT'S A QUORUM. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. LET'S FIRST TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 1965.
BLANCA RUBIO, PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS. AND
NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2119
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER, MENTAL
HEALTH, DO I HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SO MOVED.
OKAY, SENATOR GROVE MOVES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR ROSS. AYE.
ROTH. AYE WHEN I WHEN I GLASER.
GLASER I. GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE
I HURTADO I HURTADO I LIMÓN.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. I. RUBIO. I.
RUBIO I. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WIENER CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
SEVEN VOTES. WILL HOLD THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWO. EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN. FOOD DATE
LABELING. MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
INTO THE FLOOR. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. DO WE HAVE A MOTION? WE
NEED A MOTION. SO MOVED BY SEN.
HURTADO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I ROTH I WHEN I
WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE. I
HURTADO. HURTADO I LIMÓN.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I. RUBIO.
RUBIO. I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WIENER. MATTER. HAS SEVEN VOTES.
WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE. AB 1842 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. MEDICATION
ASSISTANT TREATMENT. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION? SO MOVED.
SENATOR HURTADO MOVES THE MATTER
. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH. AYE. ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ. GROVE
GROVE I HURTADO HURTADO I LIMÓN
I LIMÓN I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
RUBIO I RUBIO I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WIENER MATTER HAS EIGHT
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL
1977 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. BEHAVIORAL
DIAGNOSIS. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. DO
I HAVE A MOTION? SO MOVED,
SENATOR HURTADO? YES OKAY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH. AYE ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER. GLASER. I GONZALEZ.
GROVE I GROVE I HURTADO HURTADO
I LIMÓN I LIMÓN I MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I RUBIO. RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER MATTER
HAS EIGHT VOTES WILL HOLD THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM ITEM NUMBER 6AB 2449 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. QUALIFIED AUTISM
SERVICE PROVIDERS. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. IS THERE A
MOTION? SO MOVED BY SENATOR
GROVE, PLEASE CALL THE ROLE
SENATOR ROTH I ROTH I WHEN I
WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I.
GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE I HURTADO
. LIMÓN I LIMÓN. I MENGIBAR.
RUBIO. RUBIO. I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER SIX. MATTER. AS
SIX VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2435 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. IS THERE A MOTION?
THE BILL? MENGIBAR. SENATOR
MENGIBAR MOVES THE BILL. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR ROTH A
ROTH. AYE. WHEN GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER WE NEED TO
RECALL. CHANGE A VOTE. NO.
SORRY. GROVE. I TO. NO. OKAY SO.
7 TO 1. YES. VOTE COUNT ON AB
2435 IS 7 TO 1. WE'LL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
LAST ITEM, ITEM NUMBER NINE.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2995, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, JACKSON PUBLIC HEALTH.
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAMS.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
IS THERE A MOTION BLAZER?
SENATOR GLAZER MAKES THE MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH A ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ.
GROVE. GROVE. I HURTADO. HURTADO
I LIMÓN. LIMÓN I MENGIBAR. I
MENGIBAR. I. RUBIO I. RUBIO. I.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I WIENER. WIENER. I IS
THAT IT FOR THE DAY? DO ANYBODY
MISSING? WE'RE MISSING GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ WAITING FOR GONZALEZ.
THE VOTE ON AB 2995 IS TEN ZERO.
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. DID I VOTE NO?
YES. THAT ONE. YEAH. OKAY. YOU
WANT ME TO CALL TO OPEN IT UP
FOR THE REST. AND I. BUT I VOTED
ON 2995. YEAH. OKAY. REMEMBER
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S LET'S JUST
GO BACK THROUGH AND PICK UP
WHOEVER NEEDS TO BE PICKED UP
HERE. WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE AGAIN. GO BACK THROUGH THE
ITEMS FIRST. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE ARE TWO ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR A B 20 1965 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO,
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS AND ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
AB 2119, BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER MENTAL HEALTH. THE VOTE IS
7 TO 0. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SURE. VOTING AYE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ LIMÓN. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE. THIS VOTE IS TEN
ZERO. WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. LET'S CALL
ITEM NUMBER TWO. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. FOOD DATE LABELING
. MOTION IS BE ADOPTED INTO THE
FLOOR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO
0. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ
LIMÓN. Ã. LIMÓN. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
WIENER WIENER. AYE CURRENT VOTE
TEN ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROW OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB 1842.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WIENER. AYE CURRENT VOTE TEN
ZERO. HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL, 1977
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. BEHAVIORAL
DIAGNOSES. DIAGNOSIS. THE MOTION
DO PASS AS AMENDED. RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 8 TO 0. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WIENER. WIENER I. CURRENT VOTE
TEN ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 2449.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE QUALIFIED AUTISM
SERVICE PROVIDERS MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. CURRENT VOTE
SIX ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ HURTADO. MENGIBAR.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER. WIENER. AYE
CURRENT VOTE. EIGHT ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. LET'S CALL ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. AB 2435 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE. MOTION
TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. CURRENT VOTE 7 TO
1 CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WHEN GONZALEZ
WIENER Ã WIENER. AYE AT EIGHT
ONE. CURRENT VOTE 8 TO 1 WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. IT SHOULD BE IT FOR
EVERYBODY. THAT'S. YEP YEP. JUST
MISSED IT. I DON'T REMEMBER WHEN
I'M ON EVERYTHING. YES. YEP.
YOU'RE GOOD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I'VE GOTTEN TO THAT POINT
WHERE I.
HEALTH COMMITTEE WILL STAND IN
RECESS FOR FIVE MINUTES.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
WILL RECONVENE IN, AND WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL AND WE'RE
GOING TO START BY OPENING THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTS OF ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB
1965. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCO
RUBIO, PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF
TRIBAL AFFAIRS, AND ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN, AB 2119 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER MENTAL HEALTH ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 10 TO 0. PLEASE OPEN THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SEN. GONZALEZ AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
11 VOTE IS 11 ZERO. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT. LET'S START
THEN WITH, NEXT WITH ITEM NUMBER
TWO. ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
NUMBER TEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ERWIN. FOOD DATE LABELING. THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED INTO THE
FLOOR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 1010
TO 0. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER. SEN. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE VOTE IS 11 ZERO. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL 1842.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. MOTION IS Dð
PASS AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS TEN ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. VOTE IS 11 ZERO.
THAT MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL
1977 ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. BEHAVIORAL
DIAGNOSIS. MOTION TO PASS IS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. VOTE IS 11 ZERO.
THAT MATTER IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER
SIX. ASSEMBLY BILL 2449.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. QUALIFIED AUTISM
SERVICE PROVIDERS. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED. CURRENT
VOTE IS 8 TO 0. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE.
HURTADO MENGIBAR VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. THAT MATTER IS OUT. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2435. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE. THE
MOTION TO PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. CURRENT VOTE IS.
(967) 885-6789. NO 881 CURRENT
VOTE IS 8 TO 1. EXCUSE ME, CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER WHEN GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE CURRENT VOTE IS 9
TO 1. AND FINAL ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER NINE. ASSEMBLY. AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. CURRENT VOTE IS,
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB 2995.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON PUBLIC
HEALTH, ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAMS A MOTION TO PASS AND TO
THE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. VOTE IS 11 ZERO.
ALL ITEMS ARE OUT, INCLUDING THE
LAST ONE. HEALTH COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.